all right kings and queens of las vegas
and beyond your throne awaits at the
boulevard mall where you can have
one of the most unique dining
experiences in town
so put your crowns on and check this out
channel your primal instincts and get
ready for a dining experience off the
strip
and into the medieval times we wanted to
bring uh
something different to vegas and that's
exactly what primal steakhouse is
something different and everything but
tamed
you're going to see dim lighting with
medieval times
theme great music
[Music]
think game of thrones meets las vegas
with unique decor and antiques
hand-picked vintage chairs collected
from around the world
and food drinks and prices to die for
now we feast smoked new york steak pork
belly scavec
just to name a few crowd favorites you
can have all the
finance the finesse of the strip not the
prices
flavors all the like you know all you
can expect in front of
those restaurants strip you can find it
right here
the finesse and flavors of the strip but
also of chef angel's family
right here we got the blac ceviche this
is a guatemalan traditional ceviche i
tried to elevate a little bit of
guatemalan
so instead go shrimp i got a scalloped
and king crab legs
and we serve it with the chips fresh
yogurt chips that we actually cut it
every day and now we drink
okay eddie we are eating our medieval
steak and now we need our strong
medieval drink right what are the
flavors that go into this
so the flavor profile is gonna be more
sweet but yet strong so we're gonna
start with kettle
peach in horse boston okay we are gonna
put in some apricot brandy okay
so what makes your your signature
cocktail so unique here
i believe it's just a horn that you're
drinking out of because everybody's
gonna
grab the horn and look at it and be like
well i feel like i should be sitting on
a throne
i am gonna add also uh even pours of
orange juice and cranberry okay
see the scales there and then what i am
gonna do is ask you to go ahead and put
in
the dry ice hey
you've got a special rhythm going on
years of bartending
and then you want to go ahead and pour
that into the top
the dry ice effect very medieval we call
it the viking punch
all right it's ready for me to drink yes
it is i feel like i need a
a good medieval line this
is
[Music]
too much fun at primal i loved it there
thank you so much to primal steakhouse
for sponsoring this segment check out
the steakhouse at boulevard mall for
more information or to make your
reservation just call 702-620-5103
or visit primalsteakhouse.com we'll be
right back